our first guest is a pro Football Hall
of Famer that you can catch every single
day with Nick ride on fs1
first things first along with Jenna wolf
as well from 6:30 to 9:30 a.m. Eastern
Time and you can catch this gentleman on
the call with SH lares and Stockton ruff
Panthers at Browns this Sunday on Fox
that games taking place in the state of
Ohio Chris Carter on the program how are
you Chris really how you doing that jump
just thrilled that you're you're here I
really AM man because I love watching ya
I love your take and I'm here to take
hit if you care to dish it out you know
Chris you see what I'm saying I got you
rich I got you
I come in peace that's greatly
appreciated all right so let's get into
it what why did urban step down Chris
what do you think here look its yearly
health I mean we've talked about urban
just happens to be one of my close
personal friends mm-hmm so I would say I
wasn't involved in the process but I was
one of the people a little over a month
ago when him and Jean Jean Smith
athletic director at OSU started having
conversations about what his overall
health was potentially moving forward
what was going to be the best so he did
confide in me over a month ago that this
was one of the three options that he was
facing the other two options weren't
great options either and so I know I
took a lot through a lot out of him this
family Shellie the kids met with his
wife this weekend before the
northwestern game so I think there is a
sense of release because there is a
danger every time he goes out there
every time that he is in full coaching
mode you know trying to encourage trying
to get a message across that he's in the
jeopardizes the potential of that sis
leaking and when it does he gets these
massive headaches and the Indiana game
we saw where it it made him double over
he was on one knee there struggling to
try to get his wits about himself so
that's not something any of his friends
or family
ever wanted to see again so there was
real dangers in him continuing to coach
so then when he's doubled over again the
Maryland game and it's a crucial moment
the game and everybody's huddling up a
few yards away from the sideline trying
to figure out what what to do and he's
doubled over not even in that even that
huddle that's what one of these episodes
was Chris yeah there were a couple there
were a couple of the Maryland the
Indiana the Indiana was the most
prominent because that's I think when
people first that was their first
glimpse of him and but that's the
reality when you have the cyst the size
of a tennis ball you know in your brain
that is the his overall reality and his
overall reality as far as his body
failing him where he can't be on the
sidelines anymore so Chris Carter Hall
of Famer here on the Richard show one
all in the old-time Ohio State greats
here from fs1 as well on the Rich Eisen
show so when when his wife hugged him at
the end of that Michigan game the game
against Michigan it looked to me when I
I saw it like that looked like a family
that knew that was their last day and
the horseshoe did he know at that point
in time Chris um I wouldn't say that he
knew but just getting through that game
and not being a hindrance to the kids
with the opportunity for some seniors to
go for and own against Michigan to be
able to move on potentially to build get
into the playoffs
getting to the Big Ten championship all
those things but right there you could
see even round sports long enough rich
that there was a lot of release there
you know a guy that's won three national
championships he beats his rival
Michigan to go seven know against them
in the last seven years
but that wasn't just a hug about that it
was something deeper and you're right
you sense this a sense of relief from
that family
and what that Michigan game urban was
worrying about being a distraction a
distraction for the kids distraction for
the University and to be able to get
through that in the way the kids play
the way the kids took to the coaching
that week that was with that hug and
that embracing those tears with
and I've been around as you said sports
long enough I've also been around
coaches long enough they never ever ever
get it out of their system never ever
ever with a capital T V er get it out of
their system well do you think in a
couple years that he feels better he's
not feeling the pain from the cyst or
and it doesn't prove that he does coach
again um no I definitely think that was
the last we'll see of him that will be
in the Rose Bowl I think that Ervin and
we've just talked about other outlets
that he can utilize his coaching his
leadership ability in other capacity so
we do believe like he does have an
afterlife
you know after coaching but you are
right I'm glad that he does have a
medical condition compared to what we've
seen because there is there's nothing
that replaces plane there's nothing that
replaces coaching and that's why we've
seen people Teeter totters you know
playing and are coaching and you're
right if he didn't have that cyst and or
I didn't know the family know the wife
like he's got real real life issues as
far as moving forward and what's the
best way for him to be so that he can
enjoy the rest of his life coaching
won't be a part of it last one on this
subject then Chris do you think that
what happened with Zach Smith and the
suspension and the three games played
into just maybe the physical tiredness
on top of his brain cyst to lead to this
decision at all Chris no I don't I don't
think the Zach because you know urban
took some heat for that and rightfully
so I mean when you when you run a
program you know man the buck stops at
the dude who's making the shot so if
it's right if it's wrong you always
going to get some heat when you don't
know your assistants as intimately as
you think you expected head coach so
you're going to get some heat from that
but I know urban I know him well enough
it rich I would tell you and we had
talked in the last year about urban co2
another four or five years urban thought
he had the the program in the position
that he can make a run a couple more
national championships he talked about
potentially to how the next four
potentially getting into the playoffs
and having the opportunity to win so it
was the type of talent they have
they're quarterbacks of South Warren
they got another good quarterback up
100m Tate Martel if it trust me with
this type of team out there
urban would stay out there you know
that's the way you resolve the zachsmith
you just you you you you outlast it and
you keep winning so no I believe it did
wear on him because his overall image
and what people thought about him as a
leader it took a hit but no I didn't
where to lead to the SIS growing it
didn't lead to the SIS
as you know rupturing can fluid being
released into them notes that part
didn't but it is it did take a toll on
urban personally and before you get to
the NFL one last one on this how does it
work with him being around you know I
mean Ryan day as you point out has a a
great set up there's no there's no way
to describe it other than a great setup
but one assumes he will not win 82 of
his first 91 I mean that's just that's
that's purple unicorn stuff so how with
him there if Ryan Day does have the
usual struggles of a first-year head
coach or somebody who's never done it
before or isn't going to win 82 of his
first 91 how does it work with with the
pressures and an urban being there
physically well I didn't I I think this
right now everyone's looking for the new
shot expect who's gonna be the next Sean
McVeigh urban and Gene Smith feel like
they have the next John McVay in college
football in Ryan day so they have great
expectations for them the program is in
as good a shape or is it could ever been
for a new coach and I think this is
important I think a lot of people miss
this when you get a new coach and we
have to benefit up we didn't do a
national search so we don't have our fan
base splintered all a man they should
have hired this guy all they should have
hired this guy we have all the support
from Buckeye Nation going to one person
the roster is fact and every decade look
at Ohio State the last hundred years
they have won in every decade so why
would I be concerned I'm not concerned
at all you know people were concerned
could urban live up to what Trussell did
hmm I think
did that and add it to the history a
little bit so we're very very confident
Ryan day moving forward but more
importantly as a university and has a
fan base we're all moving in the same
direction to make sure that he gets the
same support that Ervin and every other
coach got at the Ohio State all right
Chris let's move on to the game you're
calling this is a pretty big one man
with the Panthers now suddenly six and
six it seems like the new owner there
might have an itchy trigger finger for
Ron Rivera and with the way that
Mayfield and the Browns have been
playing now two and two under Gregg
Williams this could be a potential type
I mean a Mike McCarthy game I'm not
saying they're gonna bounce him right in
the middle of the season but this this
would be this has all the makings of the
Browns making life very difficult for
Carolina how do you see it that you're
calling this well first of all when you
talk about Cleveland rich you've been
watching them and yes it's equated to
wins and everything but man they got us
to man they got a good roster they got a
good offensive line I got a good
defensive line they play some good
defense under Gregg Williams so it's not
as if you're just going into Cleveland
late you know and you're on it you're in
the tailspin and you're gonna get
potentially upset by a Cleveland team
that's not very very talented no they
have a good quarterback as young and
Baker Mayfield so this is a tremendous
challenge and when you have a new owner
you'd like to go to sit around and build
like the K what's going to be his style
now the owner there he did come from the
Pittsburgh Steelers but that don't mean
he's going to be as patient as the
Steelers nation has been it's be hard
for any organization to be as patient as
great and supportive as they have so
it's something to watch behind the
scenes Ron Rivera is it fair he got a
new owner but the last three years he's
had a new defensive coordinator Shawn
McDermott now coaching in Buffalo last
year's defense according our coaching in
Arizona so him taking over the defense
from Eric Washington how they finished
these last four games I believe it could
tilt the scale not only to Ron Rivera
but ultimately it's Cam Newton the
quarterback in Carolina I believe those
are two questions the Carolina winning
games will help them and the bill to
help get answers or get those things
results fine as you know
quarterback driven league you just you
just talked about cam and your
one-year-old teams the Minnesota Vikings
just a dreadful day in Foxborough
which'll happens to a lot of people for
Kirk Cousins but this is his first foray
of his guaranteed contract now he goes
to Seattle do you think he's got but
what it takes for the Vikings to get to
where they want to go Chris yeah rich I
like Kirk Cousins
I think Kurt is a really good
quarterback I think he throws I think
his arm is really underrated the tough
throws that he can make but just from a
gameplan standpoint you have Adam
Thielen having an outstanding season you
have Diggs have an outstanding season
now digs has been nicked up the last
several weeks it was kind of slowed up
his productivity but if you're gonna
attack a New England defense all right
because it's not the same challenge
going to Seattle you know III know we
say all these young coordinators you
know you know they're exciting
everything but I was a little
disappointed in D filippo because I
thought you under utilized the tight end
all season all right Dalvin cook is
underutilized now he hadn't been healthy
but going there you know you have to use
eyes those two positions doing them is
not gonna let a wide receiver beat them
I mean so they just double the guys
outside play single coverage and either
they played way way off or they blitzed
a whole bunch so and when you blitz they
make you so hot so they make you not
convert on third down so to me I didn't
like the game planning and I'm not going
to criticize Kirk Cousins when you don't
use your tight ends you don't use your
running backs there's the right way
you know I'm looking at other things
there in Minnesota bill help support
Kirk if Alvin cooked healthy and that
offensive line is good they should be a
very very explosive offense but I'm
still a little concerned of how they're
packaging their talent and how they're
presenting it on this oh no all the
weekly base and then what do you think's
going on in the Redskins locker room
right now Chris they're half game behind
the Vikings for the wild card they're a
game out of first place they are flat
out in this mix and Colin Kaepernick
isn't even being brought in they said
they were considering Jay Gruden said
yesterday they were considered
but he's not a fit for for this offense
to get him up to speed in time for the
end of this season but I guess Josh
Johnson is I know that he might have had
more history he had he hasn't thrown a
pass since 2011 I'm wondering what you
think of all this rich you know what's
criminal well we know colin is well
enough but people's politics are getting
in the way of their football you know
you have certain organizations they have
supported what's going on in Washington
and which in turn is it they have help
that has bled into how they're gonna
fill out their roster now I just don't
understand how a guy can slap a female
allegedly in Rueben foster on a Saturday
and then me and the rest of my
organization decide we're gonna put in a
claim for him and he deserves to play
for our team but Colin Kaepernick
because of his social justice because he
wants to make people aware of what's
going on he can't play for your team
oh but Josh Johnson can play for your
team like okay so you letting something
get in the way so let the Redskins fans
know this you're not gonna put the best
football team on the field you gonna put
a team out there that you're gonna pick
and choose and it's not going to be the
best player the thing with captain
upsets me is rich we've been preaching
this we work with the network we work
with the NFL we tell people we can and
week out this is the 1700 best players
in the world we can't say that no more
because they have decided that caps
shouldn't be a part of the league so we
can't tell we can't even stand behind
the shield and say that no more so now
it's not necessarily about the best
players so we've been about the best
when the NFL gets back to being about
the best Colin Kapernick will be in a
uniform and on NFL five yeah I mean to
me I we should be past this at this
point I mean it's it's I'm serious
though a bra and it's it's kind of
likeable you know and and and and I see
fans on Twitter say you know I'd rather
lose out all the rest of our games well
guess what
the Giants are coming to town just like
you and I communicate enrich it would it
would be idiotic for you and I to say
you know something I'm not gonna have
people from Ohio state involved in my
program when I get on TV I'm not gonna
talk about them
Chris Carter's not going to talk about
this again oh I hate Charles sight
that's stupid like it's stupid Michigan
Ohio State gonna be part of the National
Football League all right so and it'd be
smart for us to include them and their
players and their coaches in the
conversation yeah by the way one of our
you know show Booker's uh right here
instead she went to Ohio State and if it
was it's been very difficult as Chris to
come to work lately
I'll be very oh yeah yeah yeah I
understand man how many you said you
were coming in peace its back Oh
but but I leave with a little grenades
Chris man I love chat with you thanks
for calling in and say hi to Nick right
and everybody else there at first things
first I will keep up the good work too
man you know I'm a big big fan of you
right back at you that's Chris Carter
Pro Football Hall of Famer at Chris CR
is Carter ad on Twitter the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience